what is up everybody it's animak here
from
anime uproar and today i will be
discussing the latest
insane twist in the black clover story
the vice captain of the black balls may
have been an impostor
this entire time he may have been
impersonating
someone else all along this was honestly
crazy
and mind-blowing so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the black lore content
here on the channel please leave a like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps a lot
and if you're new to animal pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications if you want to avoid
missing a bunch of our videos you really
have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting that bell and then
selecting the option that says
all i know it's annoying but that's just
how youtube works
finally this video will of course
contain black clover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution
you have been warned okay so the new
chapter starts off sometime
before noel and the heart kingdom gang
arrive
at the spade kingdom capital the
unofficial translation says
a few hours before but a few hours seems
like a really long
time a lot could happen in a few hours
so we'll have to double check with the
official translation which is not yet
out
at the time of me making this video but
the main
point is that this is all happening
before the events
of the previous chapter before we saw
knocked
seemingly unconscious and impaled upon
the magic
of lilith and nama and speaking of
lilith and namah
as chapter 285 begins they are excited
to have some fun
and fight it out with the humans but
knock
knows that he has to separate these two
highest ranked devils from dante
that is the only way that the spade
kingdom infiltration squad
might succeed in actually taking dante
down
lilith and the mob both appear to be
complete psychos who just want to
destroy
torture and kill everyone around them
and yet
dante is extremely excited that these
two devils have entered the world
because having strong devils like them
emerged from the underworld is exactly
what his plan was
all along however lilith and amma don't
appear to have any respect for dante
despite the fact that dante played a
crucial role in opening the tree of
cliffhoth and letting them enter this
world
they just call him lucifer's toy in a
mocking way
also i am trying very hard not to
mention lilith's assets
in this video because here at anime
uproar we are strictly professional and
stuff
so wish me luck so while dante is busy
simping for those high tier devils
an injured jack steps up to him and says
that he
is still dante's opponent jack vows to
slice
dante but dante isn't scared at all he
just seems excited and delighted at the
prospect of fighting jack
as every psychotic weirdo would be
knocked
is forced to leave the difficult task of
fighting dante to jack
as he prepares to summon his fourth
devil the one who looks like a rooster
nacht calls this devil war gunner
although we'll have to see if that name
changes once we get the official
translation i'm betting that it probably
will
apparently noct had given this rooster
devil
some other mission very recently a
mission that the devil has
presumably completed that is very
interesting i wonder what
this mission was knocked then proceeds
to use his devil unite form
with the rooster devil to unlock yet
another epic form
gallus in this latest form knocked looks
like a mixture of a bird
and a plague doctor from the middle ages
and he now has
access to some pretty amazing abilities
he first uses an ability called
scream to briefly immobilize lilith
and naman and he then uses his shadow
magic
to pull the two devils down through the
floor and into a separate chamber of the
castle
noct proceeds to use dark prison hunting
ground
to engulf the entire chamber in shadows
which results in total darkness
ensuring that lilith and ama will not be
able to see
anything noct then begins the game of
tag from hell
as he attempts to dodge these two devils
and avoid their attacks
inside this pitch-black space he tries
his best to attack the two devils
but unfortunately they are so strong
that his attacks are not having any
effect
noct decides that all he can do is keep
dodging for as long as possible
until he is eventually killed but he
hopes that even if he dies he will be
able to at least contribute to the fight
against the devils by trapping them
inside his dark prison noct proclaims
that he does not forgive
unjust evil and that he doesn't mind
dying
for his cause and then we finally get to
see some of noct's backstory through a
sudden
flashback noct is a member of the faust
noble family and he had a twin brother
named
morgan morgan means morning in german
so one brother is named morning and the
other is named
knight the younger brother was a role
model who was loved by many people
and who became a magic knight so that he
could save others
the older brother who had white hair
rather than black hair
had bad manners and he used magic only
for his own
selfish reasons the younger brother who
looks exactly like the nocht we know
tried convincing the older brother to
join the magic knights in order to help
them
save more people but the older brother
didn't see any point in that
that didn't seem like fun to him and his
own amusement
is the only thing that the older brother
really cared about we then see yami
suddenly show up as the two brothers are
talking to each
other and it is then revealed that the
brother with the dark hair
the younger brother who became a magic
knight and who looks exactly like the
noct we know
is not knocked at all his name
is morgan so he is not knocked
the brother with the long white hair is
the real
knock like what and that
is how this crazy chapter ends on that
massive cliffhanger which suggests that
the noct we know has a secret identity
so what exactly does this mean then
morgan the younger brother
died at some point and then knocked
decided to join the black bulls
in order to honor his brother did he
also change his
appearance to look like his brother in
order to pay tribute to him
i can definitely see something like that
happening
like maybe morgan died in action at some
point in the past and knocked felt
terrible because he thought that if he
had joined the magic knight and fought
by his brother's side like his brother
had wanted him to
he may have been able to save morgan's
life
so then out of guilt noct decides to
take his brother's place
in the magic knights and maybe he also
assumes the appearance of his brother
because he wants to be more like his
selfless brother and less like his own
selfish self
this would definitely explain why noct
keeps saying that he hates
yami nakht was not yami's old comrade
from the azure deer squad
morgan was so maybe nakt actually
resents yami for not
protecting his brother since the two of
them were comrades
this is the scenario that i am
personally leaning towards
but with that said there might be more
to this story
or something totally different could be
going on here
i can totally see noct joining the magic
knights because that's what his brother
wanted him to do
but then why completely copy his younger
brother's appearance as well
that part is a little sus as if he's
trying to trick people into thinking
that he is his younger brother
but anyway what do you guys think what
is really going on
with this knocked morgan twist let me
know
down in the comments by the way this
reveal
also explains one image from much
earlier on in the manga when we see a
silhouette of the black
bulls one of the silhouettes is a guy
with long white hair
and this guy was never identified so
back before we knew who the vice captain
was
many people theorized that this was this
mysterious vice captain
but then when nocht was introduced in
the story his appearance was totally
different
so most people assumed that this
white-haired silhouette was not
knocked however noct's original
appearance before he started copying his
brother
is a perfect match for this silhouette
so yeah
that was knocked i think that one
important piece of information that
might end up being crucial for
unraveling this entire mystery
is noct's surname faust johann georg
faust also known as dr faustus was a
mysterious german alchemist who lived in
the late 1400s
and early 1500s faust was such an
interesting guy
that after his death he became the
subject of
folk tales and eventually a legend
sprung up about
faust making a deal with the devil
according to the legend faust was very
successful in his life but he was
dissatisfied because he wanted more
so he ended up selling his soul to the
devil in exchange for
unlimited knowledge and worldly
pleasures
this is very interesting because we know
that noct was initially only interested
in selfish
worldly pleasures and of course we know
that he made a pact with a devil or
multiple devils so that he could use
their magic
now in most versions of the story faust
ends up being condemned to hell
so that's not really a great sign for
knocked but whatever happens i'm excited
to see how the elements from the faust
legend are going to be incorporated in
the story
faust has been referenced in many other
works of fiction including in blue
exorcist for those of you who are
familiar with that series
it's definitely a fascinating legend so
it's cool to see tabata
incorporating this into the story i
can't wait to see how
all of it plays out but what do you guys
think
what is yami's true relationship with
noct and how did noct become the vice
captain of the black bulls
if his brother morgan was the one who
was friends with yami
also is knocked about to sacrifice his
life
for the black bulls or are austin and
the others going to arrive
in time to save him definitely share
your feedback
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
black lover content right here on the
channel please leave that like
to let me know and if you are new to
anime out pro or maybe you watch our
videos but you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications if you don't want to
miss a ton of our videos in the future
you really have to go through the
trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says
all you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram
at animeopror a big thank you to all of
our anime outpour patrons for making
videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
the world a quiet respect pate heffa
liam thompson
algertal dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life chanel baked
buddhist and tungsten tarkis
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh
steelers on hell cruise anatoly kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
fond raphaeline de ora
alicia octor bonnie parks hinokami and
water the red-haired raven joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games ted no
ted deadly saint matthew cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you